[Music]
when you're a kid
i think the universe revolves around you
then one day you realize that's not true
into the story of a bunch of kids that
wake up to something terrible happening
here take it down
terry is in a town that is quite
unsettling
what's with the history project why is
it all murders of missing kids
dairy's not like any time i've ever been
in before
people die or disappear six times the
national average
everyone knows that there's something
wrong about this whole situation
my grandfather thinks this town is
cursed that all the bad things that
happen in this town are because of
one thing
it comes back every 27 years and
more kids disappeared i saw something
the clown
yeah i saw him too it turns out that
all the murders in derry all the missing
children
are all connected look
it's all connected by the sewers that's
where it lives
what happened
[Applause]
what is that
the entity that is pennywise focuses
on whatever that particular child fears
the most
it is anything that you are ever afraid
of
it's definitely overcoming that fear and
we do it because we're with each other
hanging out with us makes you loser too
i can take that that really bonds
together because we really have nowhere
else to turn
there's no one else who really cares for
us we all know no one else is going to
do anything
these kids find strength and being
together
we can't pretend it's going to go away
bill if you'll come with me you'll float
too
[Music]
it's very emotional
and it's terrifying i had hopes but i
was not prepared
for how good it really was i'm sure my
fans will
really enjoy the movie
[Music]
when you're a kid i think the universe
revolves around you
you think that you'll always be
protected and cared for
then one day you realize that's not true
because when you're alone as a kid
the monsters see you as weaker
you don't even know they're getting
closer
[Music]
until it's too late
my grandfather thinks this town is
cursed
that all the bad things that happen in
this town are because of one thing
an evil thing
bill if you'll come with me we'll float
[Music]
i saw something a clown yeah i saw him
too
what happens when another georgie goes
missing
or one of us
are you just gonna pretend it isn't
happening like everyone else in this
town
if we stick together
[Music]
way
[Music]
you